hallo mein name ist luca meine lieben
freunde herzlich willkommen wir heute zu
einem spiel bei dem ich so richtig rein
schießen werde
denn wir spielen das auction game und
dabei müssen wir preise von produkten
erraten ich könnte jetzt nicht nur sagen
wie teuer bin nehme ich im supermarkt
ist dementsprechend klicken wir einfach
mal auf start- und sehen hier ein
dollars sein es ist also ein bild von
andy warhol das ist aber den habe ich
schon irgendwo gehört das bild ist von
1981 und kostet dementsprechend die
meiner auffassung nach das hier
die 20 milliarden ist bisschen zuviel
2,09 8 millionen dollar für das ding
dementsprechend klicken wir jetzt hier
auf den hammer und sehen es kostet das
fast so teuer wie wir ticken wir
allerdings direkt weiter auf next und
seen forever bicycles es ist also auch
ein kunstwerk von ai weiwei
das kunstwerk ist aus dem jahre 2003 und
das beinhaltet er ganz viele fahrräder
und basically sieht jede fahrradstation
und holland oder amsterdam also aus
sondern er denke ich mal dass es nicht
allzu teuer sein wird also in kunst
fachsprache nicht allzu teuer von der
würde ich sagen nach halbe millionen
dollar und ich bin gespannt denn es
kostet hier wirklich auf einem guten weg
richtig guter weil warum also kunst hin
oder her aber warum kauft man sich denn
so was wenn er jetzt 2020 stehen würde
würde ich sagen 10 dollar da das
allerdings von 1955 ist würde ich sagen
200.000 mehr nicht für diesen komischen
frosta
da hätte ich mal doch die 50 dollar
genommen
das ist das nächste bild was wir
erwarten müssen ich find das halt
überhaupt nicht schön zudem ist es aus
dem jahr 2002 von daher würde ich sagen
das kostet 20.000 euro wenn es hier drin
ist dann muss es eben wert haben 146
1000 nicht so scheiße im rahmen
concentric square
das mache ich dir in photoshop
das von einer minute okay es ist von 19
66 da gab's photoshop vielleicht doch
nicht ich würde einfach mal sagen weil
es ja so richtig komische leute gibt die
versuchung mal viel geld ausgeben
393.000 333 dollar und ich bin ganz weit
weg
wieso bin ich denn so scheiße
und das ist einfach so einen klotz also
ich weiß nicht ob ich das nicht richtig
einschätzen kann oder nicht richtig
wertschätzen kann allerdings ist das
meiner auffassung nach halt einfach
sondern kupfer blog oder seid ihr so ein
bisschen was raus gekehrt mit super g
mit sondern mit so einer eiskeller
30.000 euro aber das wirklich schon das
ist schon zuviel dafür finde ich und es
sind 62.000 was kauft man sich lieber
alter mercedes amg oder so einen
komischen käse blog hier kann ich's
realtech verstehen wir das jetzt in
siebenstelliger oder achtjähriger betrag
es war das ist aus dem jahre 1912 und
sieht ziemlich wild aus nicht richtig
hoch leute ich die auf 15 millionen das
sind
vier punkte es ist genauso wie sander in
den abi hatte in der vorletzten runde
müssen den preis von diesem tor so
erraten
die sache ist also ein torso ist ja ein
oberkörper glaube ich oder bin ich jetzt
komplett auf dem stein gefallen
aufsteigen das hat er mit dem oberkörper
fast gar nichts tun außer die form so
ein bisschen
es ist halt aus dem jahr 1906 6 und der
name henry moore kenne ich auch von
daher ich geh auf drei millionen es geht
schnell hoch und wir sind hier sind auf
jeden fall
ich bin da wirklich zufrieden bei mir in
der letzten runde meine lieben freunde
aber ein kunstwerk von einem deutschen
und zwar daniel libeskind also der name
hört sie zumindest deutschland kann auch
sein dass es daniel libeskind ist und
dass amerikaner allerdings ist es einen
spirit haus herum ein gott der sie zu
unbequem aus also die frage ist ist es
jetzt wirklich ein stuhl weil das sieht
sehr gemalt aus oder ist es halt ein
gemälde real talk ich google mal ganz
kurz und will mal gucken wie teuer das
ist
17 505 komme ich nicht setzen von 317
1505 dollar und es sind genau
aber jetzt wissen wir zumindest wenn
jetzt komplett richtig hätten würden
1000 punkte bekommt das war jetzt die
letzte runde vor sagte ich mal auf next
und wir haben auf 2988 punkte davon ein
drittel nur von der letzten runde wo ich
fast 1000 punkte hatte allerdings will
ich sagen machen wir doch nur ohne dass
man eigentlich war es die take part 2
haben wir hier
dadurch dass das paar zwei ist und nicht
der erste teil des bildes wie kann ein
bild über zwei teile haben zumal das
dann zur hälfte dax hwk wenn ihr die
andere hälfte noch haben wollt dann
müsst ihr nur zehn jahre warten folge
teile sind nie so geil wie das ursprungs
ding von daher würde ich sagen
800.000 dollar einfach weil es halt auch
schon 70 jahre alt ist und wir sind wir
sind wir sind mein gott leute ein punkt
nicht von der maximalpunktzahl entfernt
nennt mich leonardo dicaprio alter joyce
box of the gods ist das nächstes ist
wieder 50 jahre alten das bild die welt
aus das bild sieht wild aus nämlich
nicht nur leonardo da vinci sondern auch
goethe seinen vater das bild stammt von
hans hofmann hört sich ziemlich deutsch
an
da allerdings deutsche kunst im ausland
ich als kunstkenner weiß das natürlich
deutsche kunst im ausland wird meiner
ansicht nach also würde ich das mal
vermuten nie so krass gehandelt wird bei
dieser die italienische oder
französische oder amerikanische das hat
mir also diese konstellation sind die
deutschen sind dafür bekannt scheiß
wetter weiß essen scheiß mentalität
scheiß humor von daher würde ich dem
bild weil es von den deutschen ist 50
dollar kommen am 30 05 2010 neben den
hans hofmann nicht so hopps 50.000
dollar und es
es wird
[Musik]
runde nummer drei meine lieben freunde
bevor mir irgendjemand sagt ich würde
hier zwischen durch kugeln und die
preise herausfinden und ich das jetzt
angelaufene deining table and set of ten
charts was sie taten bequem aus alexandr
0 ist es es ist alexander jetzt in
männer und frauen haben da nichts zu
sache ca 1945
das war ein scheiß jahre auf jeden fall
ich würde sagen
20.000 einfach weil's so alt ist und es
ist ganz viel also so wenig geld punkte
habe ich noch nie bekommen in keiner
einzigen runde wenn man auch null punkte
bekommen ich gebe jetzt bei dem gemälde
ist er mein gott es ist von van gogh ich
wollte jetzt erst 0 dollar ein geben
weil dann würde ich hier 100 prozentig 0
punkte bekommen aber van gogh alltag ich
würde einfach mal sagen das bild kostet
30 millionen euro das ist glaube ich das
höchste was ich bisher heute eingeben
aber allerdings ist es van gogh und wir
sind wir sind deutlich drüber
ich wollte erst 50 millionen geben aber
ich dachte nicht 50 hört sich zu kranken
runde fünf wir haben aber mein gott bin
ich verfressen oder warum darf sich dass
das direkt und corny riegel wäre ein
prototyp teddybär single band aus dem
jahr 2015 es sieht richtig geil aus und
ich glaube wenn da ein kind alterswehr
bruch das wäre also das kind wäre der
könig im kindergarten oder so ich würde
sagen das kostet 50.000 das bett die
runde nehme ich nehme ich so ohne sechs
von neun einen holst pink er was ist das
jetzt ist das bild oder warst du sie
ausüben zu müssen
da geht wirklich null dollar will ich
nichts zu bezahlen das ist das geht
nicht da angeblich einen dollar ein
und ich bin was ich habe null punkte
bekommen
aber weil man weiß nicht mehr was das
hier ist
als nächstes verkauft jemand eine
schultafel die nicht mal geputzt wurde
was ich dafür ausgeben würde wäre
hundertprozentig nur so 10 dollar was
allerdings aus dem jahr 1968 und aus new
york city ist würde ich da noch mal 30
dranhängen aber mehr kann
sorry an alle kunstkenner da draußen ist
jetzt wahrscheinlich denken bohr wie
kann er so was sagen aber das ist doch
nicht schön in die mini tafel auf amazon
für zwei euro die ich mir bestellt und
ein stück rein und ich meine das gleiche
leute meinen ersten kamen garant vollen
stunde twitter eigentlich oder weil ich
könnte verkaufen irgendwie bei dieser
website für 70 millionen euro oder
machen wir die letzten jetzt ganz
schnell einfach raten dass die normalen
hässlich aus von er will ich einfach
sagen sie bereits 1865 acht abend voll
fielmann schade okay ist und das ist
auch mein gott es sich aus dieser kopf
und der medusa mit diesem schlangen
drauf irgendwie da sage ich mal was so
kommen acht millionen geben dass es
wieder voll bin ich natürlich meine
lieben freunde wir haben in der zweiten
runde jetzt hier 2148 punkte ich bin
extrem ist darin nicht das heutige video
gefallen hat es gern einen daumen hoch
da meine lieben freunde
[Musik]